hello and welcome to this video playing
I am vaske the logon Vasilievich okay
the London system with Knight to c3 okay
set set dangerous ever known I'd be five
if it's definitely dangerous so probably
a pair Luke c8 here right and this just
looks like Carol con exchange where the
night is wrong not yeah at the end of
the world but certainly not ideal maybe
it's got 95 now and and the potential g4
I hope this is not a problem could be
though gah for this kind of stuff now g4
I can actually take with the bishop over
the nights I mean both captures are
possible that's quite nice and important
okay so let's just castle and make him I
decide on what to do with the structure
yeah a couple of these most 94s is the
easiest probably but also with the eight
comes into consideration night a four
isn't what p 3g it just looks terribly
weakening and let's see
really very surprising move 9 a-4 looked
completely normal here to look at the c
5 squared potentially play 93 for
blockade on c5 w3 the White Queen side
look sir yeah has this Swiss cheese
character cannot even take on c5 se5a
some is under pressure
not easy now to find a good move yeah I
can actually take on beforehand takes 9
p-5 rupee 5 takes Bishop b5 Bishop takes
Queen takes rook a 7mm Jim the B part
could be dangerous I also can i can just
play a six I don't know what's what's
good here but this is probably
objectively strongest okay I'm doing it
maybe this is a bad decision I have
sometimes those ideas that I have to
punish the bad play directly and 7 a-6
was just clearly better for black and
this is the kind of the punishment way
yeah winning material but the position
isn't totally simple after Bishop takes
Queen takes Luke a seven it still has
this ideas and with them um with the b
plant resign I just resign yeah I mean
this is objectively right I think but
still I was a bit concerned him this was
what I was thinking this is not so
dangerous as porn but still I was I mean
I have lost so many games from
completely winning position so I'm
really yeah I want to win first the
computer wants to go H 6-cls give me
some give some some lift okay 483 yeah
this is pretty strong i guess it
completely d values the pawn structure
and i probably will be able to pick them
up one after the other yeah I think M
was it unconventionally played opening
right here he just should go nite a form
and look at this whoops look at this
crucial square and this was my intention
it actually black is already clearly
better here as well because he doesn't
get that blockade going now yeah it
isn't great I mean
the whole setup isn't that great he can
do something simple of course like do
this and go back just trade stuff which
is such as equal yeah he loses quite
some time here now computer gives this
as well which is quite clearly
comfortable from luck b3 and now see
fire it's already minus to gym now in
how to see how does he keep a center the
engine wants to play this after which
the this line is simple and good wins
wins the queenside and okay yeah I can
also do this I mean without any
complications basically keeping the
status calls a four and a six is
inserted into he also has no most of the
best according to the comp is this after
which I am the center up so to say okay
that was a pretty clear victory against
the London system don't have that soft
thanks for watching